he's a liar he's a leaker and he's a
leftist liberal if anyone was not
convinced a former FBI director Jim
Comey's involvement in the attempted
coup from within our own government of
the duly elected winner of the 2016
presidential election I have just one
question for you are you stupid look you
don't have to buy his book or argue with
your liberal friends assuming you still
have any left just listen up commies
book tour was supposed to convince us
that he was an honorable likable decent
man doing his darndest to protect the
American people and the Constitution
that tour would put to rest any issues
that might need further explanation
beyond those limited answers inside
those rigid congressional hearing rooms
Comey would hit the trail the bookstores
and the TV studios making clear that
when he was atop his perch at the FBI he
did everything right unfortunately for
Jim it didn't quite work out as planned
in fact the man is in real legal
jeopardy with his leaks being
investigated by the Justice Department
not that I have any faith in sessions
and company that they'll ever do
anything of consequence regarding this
fiasco but last week you remember I told
you there was nothing zilch zero nada in
commis two-page memo of his meeting with
the president that in any way shape or
form incriminated president Trump just
the opposite the president denied
everything involving Russia wanted the
investigation vigorously pursued and he
wanted leakers prosecuted so what does
mr. big do he walks out and leaps to his
liberal pal Columbia Law School
professor Dan Richmond but he's not a
leaker check this one out
but you did leak you did leak memos I
mean is it okay for somebody at the FBI
to leak something an internal document
even if it's not classified isn't that
leaking well there's a whole lot wrong
with your question Anderson first I
didn't leak memos I asked a friend to
communicate the substance of one
unclassified man with Jim you're not a
leaker come on Jim you say you asked the
president if you could meet with him
privately to discuss a dossier because
it's private and you don't want others
to hear and you don't want CNN to know
but almost immediately after you do CNN
and the world has it and you actually
want us to believe you didn't leak the
dossier when you say in the memo itself
that clapper told you to tell the
president about the dossier and tell him
it won't be leaked
did you or your subordinates leak that
no did James clapper no not to my
knowledge no John Brennan I I don't know
who leaked it do you ever try to find
out who leaked an unclassified public
document no so you give a memo sent to
the deputy director of the FBI the chief
of staff of the FBI and the FBI's legal
counsel that memo to your pal Dan and
it's not a leak and you say Jim it
wasn't classified but it was marked
secret which is classified and then you
say well as a head of the FBI I could do
classified
here's the problem Jim you took a
document that was written
contemporaneous to a meeting with the
president-elect of the United States
advising him of an intelligence
investigation Jim that's a crime 18 USC
641 makes it a crime to convey any
record of of the United States or of any
department or agency to another person
and your FBI employment agreement bars
the unauthorized disclosure of
information contained in their files
electronic or paper and remember when
Barack Obama hired you you sign that you
will quote not revealed by any means any
information acquired by virtue of my
official employment to any unauthorized
recipient
so now mr. slick you tell us that your
friend Dan Richmond is a special
government employee pray tell who made
him that who did his background check
but like McCabe and Lynch you just throw
him under the bus federal regulations
require that an employee even he shall
not allow the improper use of non-public
information to further his own private
interests sense to be a special
government employee he had to be trained
and then agreed to this he had to
recognize his responsibilities regarding
unauthorized documents you know Jim you
got some set you say it's not a leak and
we should all believe it because you
said it and you're so brazen you think
you can change the rules as we go along
and we'll just follow like fools Jim
Comey has a definition of the word leak
that no one else in the house what he
says is a leak is what the rest of us
call a felony leaking is disclosing a
confidential conversation which is
exactly what he did and Jim you leak the
memo because you were an anti-trump er
who wanted to begin an intelligence
investigation and you wanted to
embarrass the president by making it
public and you didn't get the required
permission from the FBI or the DOJ to do
it and Jim you and I both know that
since it was part of an investigation it
becomes a 302 which memos cannot be
released
you know Jim my favorite part is when
you say you woke up in the middle of the
night and you realize that this memo
would be sufficient to get a special
counsel assigned and you say it really
was a personal diary as if anyone at the
FBI routinely
if ever since his or her diary as you
did to the deputy director the FBI the
chief of staff and the FBI's legal
counsel and Jim you say the guy you
admire most in government is good old
James clapper the guy who doesn't leak
or surveil us wittingly
he's another liar and a leaker who like
you hates Donald Trump
this bozo like you flatly denied leaking
the dossier he even released a statement
to the public that he assured the
incoming president that neither he nor
anyone in the Intel community was
responsible for the leak and he
expressed his profound dismay as such
and described the corrosive effects that
leaks have on our national security
meanwhile this weasel told you to tell
the president about the dossier at the
same time that he appears before a
congressional committee flatly denying
he leaked the dossier to the committee
and he has the hood spot to criticize
Donald Trump saying the Intel community
was under assault by the president but
lo and behold according to the house
Intel committee he later and had to
admit he told Jake Tapper CNN other
journalists about the dossier himself
before Trump's inauguration and now he's
on CNN's payroll and tonight isn't this
sweet as we speak Jake Tapper and
clapper are getting an award at the
White House Correspondents Dinner for
the report about the dossier which
clapper lied to Congress about the said
he never leaked but which we now know he
leaked to CNN for which everybody's
getting an award Jim you're part of an
anti-trump conspiracy violating the
fundamental rules of your own agency and
don't think that because you were a big
shot at the FBI that you can dispel the
rules to suit your own and your family's
own political agenda power Jim don't
ever forget it power is rented and you
my friend have been evicted and that's
my open